علامات مثيرة للقلق في أيسلندا حيث
تهز موجات الهزات الأرضية وتقسم
أجزاء من البلاد ويقول الخبراء إن
النشاط الزلزالي هناك من المرجح أن يزداد
سوءًا. ضربت آلاف الزلازل شبه
الجزيرة الجنوبية الغربية لأيسلندا
في الأيام القليلة الماضية يقول الجيولوجيون إنها
مرتبطة بممر تحت الأرض من
الصهارة التي تتحرك ويمكن أن
تؤدي قريبًا إلى ثوران بركاني في بلدة
جريندفيك على بعد حوالي 50 كيلومترًا من
عاصمة روفيك، وقد انشقت الأرض بالفعل
في بعض الأماكن بسبب
التقلبات تحت القشرة الأرضية،
وتم إجلاء أكثر من 3000 ساكن
يوم السبت مع  سمح لعدد قليل منهم بالعودة يوم الأحد
لاستعادة الحيوانات الأليفة والأشياء الأساسية
من منازلهم، ويقول الخبراء إن
ممر الصهارة الذي يمتد حوالي 15
كيلومترًا بالقرب من جريندفيك يمكن أن يتسبب في
ثوران بركاني وربما تدمير جزء كبير من
المدينة، وأصبحت الصهارة الآن على عمق ضحل جدًا،
لذا نتوقع ثورانًا  ثوران بركاني
في غضون ساعتين أه أقصر ولكن
على الأقل في غضون يومين على الأقل في أي مكان
على تلك الأسماك، يمكننا أن نرى
إمكانية حدوث ثوران بركاني. أعلنت أيسلندا
حالة الطوارئ وكإجراء احترازي
أغلقت بلو لاجون، وهو
منتجع صحي شهير للطاقة الحرارية الأرضية يقع بالقرب من جريندفيك
المنطقة القريبة من Grindvik معرضة للنشاط
البركاني مع ثلاثة انفجارات
في العامين ونصف العام الماضيين في عام 20121. قذف
فيشر الذي يصل طوله إلى 750 مترًا
نوافير لا في السماء مما
جذب السياح إلى
النقطة الساخنة غير المأهولة بالسكان هذه المرة بكاملها.
وحذر المسؤولون من أن المدينة قد تكون معرضة للخطر، وأن هذا الثوران قد يكون له عواقب أكثر خطورة بكثير